a rescue operation to save migrants in
the night like so many others on board
there are adults but also children
according to UNICEF nearly 50 million
children have been uprooted worldwide
they're crossing borders some forcibly
displaced some always their parents but
many are alone in theory these
children's have rights but in practice
they're often ignored meeting in
Strasburg the MEPA sounding the alarm
bell O'Malley's Alfonso pardon me lo de
persona move more so so Yvonne two days
on phone en vivo de responsibility days
obligation mogu prefer a lo haga danke
alegado key Suswam si Padre occupational
shakes please don't repair Allah see you
respect the Hagler ok no servants asleep
and in Europe these obligations are not
being met children's admission
procedures are rarely any faster than
adults frequent arbitrary detentions to
slow family reunification to fewer
locations in 2016 at the end of sep
tember only 46 unaccompanied children's
had been relocated what we need is
action not words we've got to move from
a position of of just talking about it
to understanding that it's action that's
needed and the Commission needs to stop
making excuses needs to stop being so
bureaucratic about it need you know
needs to take it as the point needs to
take action we have structures we have
mechanisms the tools exist but even such
a fundamental riders access to education
is not always being respected and yet
Europe is far from being the continent
that receives the most my
grandchildren's agreements between the
EU and through countries that are meant
to improve the management of migratory
flows require increased control the mep
say the situation is getting worse today
under 18 year olds account for half the
total number of refugees in the world
I